Die sogenannte ESWL ist ein modernes Verfahren, bei dem Harnsteine von außen mit sehr starken,
aber nicht höherbaren Ultraschallwellen zerkleinert werden.
Die Bruchstücke können dann meist über den Harn ausgeschieden werden.
Nun, die Steine werden wie gesagt mit Ultraschallwellen zerkleinert.
Der Eingriff ist, wir sagen, nicht invasiv.
Das bedeutet, dass die Schallwellen von außen über ein Gerät in den Körper gesendet werden über die Haut.
Das ist insgesamt ein risikoearnes Routineverfahren.
Häufig aber ungefährlich sind folgende Nebenwirkungen,
wie zum Beispiel Blutungen, die sie an einem blutigen Urin merken können, noch für einige Tage nach dem Eingriff.
Schmerzen sind normal und keine Anlass zur Sorge.
Die entstehen dadurch, dass dann die kleinen Fragmente und Bruchstücke durch den Harnleiter nach unten wandern.
Das kann natürlich etwas weh tun und wie gesagt auch noch Blutungen verursachen.
Das kann für einige Tage dauern und geht dann normalerweise von alleine weg.
Es gibt auch Risiken und Komplikationen, wie zum Beispiel Verletzungen des Harnleiters.
Der Harnweiter ist also die Verbindung zwischen Niere und Blase,
durch die der Harn eben in die Blase fließt von den Nieren.
Dann kann es auch zu Vernarbungen des Harnleiters kommen.
Das ist insgesamt relativ selten, aber es ist eine wichtige Komplikation, die Sie kennen müssen.